Yes, I can't hear you. Okay, is it still like that, Mario?
Ah, now it's good, then, I think.
Ah, okay, good, super.
Yes, now I can hear, yes, now it's good.
Wonderful, good, just about everyone is here now.
I'd just start, as I said, I'm recording it and you can also,
if you've missed anything, watch it again afterwards on the homepage.
I think Nikolaus is still missing, but I'll start now, no iPhone perhaps.
Good, I'll just start now, keep going.
As I said, I have only limited time, so I'd like to keep moving.
And I'll continue with Meteo-Parapente.
As I said, we have the temperature curve and the dew-point curve for the thermals.
Green is usable for us, black is too stable, and red would be very strong, but still good for us.
So simply very, very strong.
On top of that we have, on the right, the wind again with direction and strength.
It even has the thermal top there.
Even, if there's precipitation, that gets shown too.
So enough, or you actually have all.
All the inputs you need as a perfectly normal pilot.
And also of course down there with looking further into the future.
So significantly better in terms of planning, where you can go a bit further and check.
And actually as with the other emagram too, as soon as the two curves touch,
there'll be cloud formation, independent of the thermal development.
Actually very, very well visible.
Yes.
That's actually all for Meteo-Parapente.
It's simple, it's well structured and from my point of view also helpful.
Then the technology that I use, actually not extremely much.
There are just a few things where I find Burnair rather good.
There are also a few things where I think it's a bit, yes, not really needed.
And sometimes even, from my point of view, a bit too cluttered.
Through the abundance of information, I think it sometimes also makes it a bit too cluttered.
But it's still quite cool what it has to offer there.
Samples, you can choose which map to open.
Burnair map, there are launch sites and so on.
And then you can read it off.
Also very good.
And read off valley winds.
It always depends on what you've unlocked, what's enabled or not.
What can you choose there?
If we now go purely to the world forecast, what's important for us,
then it gets a bit cluttered again straight away.
You then have the seventh allure to choose,
with which you can choose.
So if at the beginning clouds and precipitation make the whole thing rather cluttered,
as is the case now, then you can just turn it off at the top left.
Then you've already got that out of the way.
And then you have, on the left, the altitude for the respective wind.
50 metres above ground, 250 metres above ground, which I don't think is bad.
The individual altitudes you can step through, with the days below,
with the actions, which I actually find very neat,
where you can look a bit further into the future.
And then you have — this is also really important — there on the right an enormous number of options to choose from.
For one thing, you can choose various backgrounds there.
So you can, for example, select satellite Google,
then you have the satellite overlay there.
And you can enter Google.
So you can play around a bit.
There you can look, what's for you the layer that makes it most clear for you.
I find Turnair-Topo not so wrong, because I don't need too much fluff around it.
And then you can work along for a while.
Then you have on the right really an enormous selection.
And that's also always dependent on what you can turn on.
But what I find really cool now, you see it already displayed,
are for me the live pressure values.
We have to look ourselves where that is.
Meteo-live differences, pressure differences.
Those are things that are already displayed for me.
Live wind values you can include.
So you can set a lot.
As I said.
But sometimes it then becomes a bit too cluttered too.
You can, if you've set too much, turn everything off again.
And then bring in step by step what you want, what you need.
Also here I actually find very cool, when you zoom out a bit further at the beginning.
And look at the whole thing from further out.
Where are there really areas with very, very strong wind?
And where are you perhaps?
A nuance more sheltered, right?
And can also step through the whole thing with the various altitudes.
1000 and here specifically at 1500 and 2000 metres you can see it outstandingly.
That's now very good.
Also with wind it's very good.
But here perhaps just a bit better.
But from my point of view, more clearly presented with the colours, this triggering at altitudes.
That's better recognisable.
So you have to credit Bernie for that.
He's done that very well.
You can really see flows very well, especially at higher elevations.
If we now go to 2000 metres, it becomes even more visible.
And I find that, I have to say, also again in terms of presentation, very good.
So you have to give him that.
He's done that very well.
If you now...
Ah, no.
If I want to look a bit more closely there,
then I've even got the Previtems displayed here.
If I open up there, it opens down there...
I have to make sure it doesn't accidentally collapse.
Opens down there.
I have to honestly admit, I find it a bit more cluttered.
So it's not quite that easy to read off where there's...
Perhaps a rather more stable stratification in there.
So you can read it off well, but I just find from a visual point of view,
I find that's been solved better at Meteo-Parapente.
But here too you see the wind presented at various altitudes,
with the fine direction and the strength, also down there then so the average
for the respective altitude.
You have the cloud-base altitude included.
Actually here also again very, very...
Lots of information.
At the very top you have the cloud amount or rather in which level they're located.
Here you see that there's even a bit of precipitation coming up.
So here too you can really pull a lot of info out.
What I find very good about all this,
is that here with the temperature you very quickly see,
how high it actually is at altitude.
So for example, we were in Ticino in 2023,
and it was really arsing cold.
At 2000, 2500 metres it was really minus 8, minus 10 degrees.
At 2500 it was then, I think, already minus 15 degrees.
And you could read that off there.
And then you were also really in the air, very quickly freezing.
And you see that here too.
Minus 6.1 degrees.
The temperature is, so very cold.
And the warm, stable strata are marked there in red.
You can see that well too.
I just find that the abundance of information makes it a bit more cluttered for me.
But in and of itself, here too you can read a lot off.
Now to my knowledge only with the relevant subscription.
As I said, that...
For you the wind is actually what's important.
And here too you can really play with the wind at the various altitudes.
Because I just find still cool, are the live pressure differences between north and south.
And above all a bit better broken out.
That means most varied also a bit more in that direction.
So that for me is already a decent bit of information that's there.
And with that you can also prepare very well.
A general forecast, you always have to look.
I'd use a maximum of three such apps.
And then try to find out which for you, ahead of the others, is the most reliable.
And then perhaps even work with only two.
But maximum three, I'd have said.
And that's also always good to have for comparison.
Then you see very, very quickly which one you can work well with at your location.
As I said, you always have the option to overlay precipitation and clouds.
And there you just have to look.
As soon as there's a hatched marker there, it means the clouds are touching the terrain there.
So the detail here is all cloud-touching.
Cloud-covered, cloud-covered.
Those are again very, very well done.
And precipitation areas are then logically shown here in blue-green.
So here a decent precipitation.
And so you can also read off cloud amount, cloud height even, and the precipitation.
I find that actually very well done.
As I said, you can check, there are.
From Bernie there are extensive explanations.
You can read extremely much out of his app.
I'd reduce it to the minimum for you.
Because there too I've now made the experience that the forecast,
it does take the ICON model, but I find the forecast is rather on the significantly more pessimistic side.
Working only with Burnair means for me also really significantly less flying and what's not fundamentally wrong.
But if you know that, then you can also perhaps take another app on top of it.
And then you'll perhaps have significantly more flying days.
So if you only prepare with Burnair, in my view it's a bit too pessimistic.
But as an additional source of information.
I find extremely important and good.
Whoever hasn't taken out a subscription yet, you can put that in the chat afterwards.
You can save 10 Francs there with a voucher code from me, on the respective subscription, and so save yourselves a bit more.
But also here zooming out, zooming in really very well possible and makes really visually visible,
where there's more wind, where there are perhaps areas with less wind, where I can rather go fly.
And what's really very, very well presented here, here you can really very quickly see with 1500 and 2000-metre altitudes
and makes visually really well visible.
And I find that, especially now for today's or rather tomorrow's day, where a lot of altitudes is reported, yes, I find that very good.
And it works.
Works also with weaker altitudes very well.
So that's my experience, I find it very successful in terms of presentation.
Good, that's so wind, clouds, precipitation.
With those three apps you can actually work your way through very well.
You should always also look at the surface pressure.
You have that with me on the app anyway.
There you have respectively the measurement and the forecast from MeteoSwiss.
It's right on top of each other, which is also very good.
But whoever wants to look a bit further ahead, we've seen, you can with Windy and the isobars.
But from the German Weather Service, there's also this forecast chart, which is created earlier by the Weather Service.
But there you have on the page itself, you have the option.
There naturally.
Into the.
Future to look and you still see anyway
not just isobars, but also the associated
customers. That's actually also still
important for me, for my preparation. There I can
really up to 108 hours into the future look and
see straight away, are we more in high-pressure influence or
closer to low-pressure influence, when we go further
onto Saturday.
Saturday is then the transition day. Sunday looks, I think, not so
bad, but quite strong Bise. Right, you can
actually see there what affects us.
Whereas, if we say what's the case in the analysis,
we're fully in low-pressure influence, in the
so-called warm sector. Bit caught between the individual fronts
we're stuck there quasi.
And I find that actually only a very cool variant, to
look significantly further into the future, what now
the surface pressure distribution and the large-scale weather situation are concerned.
There you have to look at the German Weather Service
under Data, Instructions
and Analysis and Forecasts.
I can put you the link directly into WhatsApp
in.
If you want to save it, I find that actually quite cool
and it's a very good preparation. As I said, the
analysis as well as the pre-computation of
MeteoSwiss, which on the phone
every Swiss has by now,
the pre-computation of the surface-pressure chart
always goes for 1 pm local time.
You can then always very, very well
compare with each other.
That for me actually also belongs to the preparation.
Then those of you who are registered at the
Meteo section, which also offers very many information,
among other things again another wind diagram,
different in the respect that it has a different scaling.
From the day itself it's again a bit better.
But certainly, yes, whether you can fly there in the afternoon or not.
What I don't find quite so good is just the boundary of five
hPa, that has often shown that four is actually from four onwards
it then really became noticeably strong.
And so I think, four is still such a boundary
that you shouldn't go above.
From my point of view.
That's why I'm not so happy with the boundary at five.
But what's a bit better presented is south is down there and north is up there.
There it gets a bit closer to reality.
I want to tell you, I have there or there's also from the German Weather Service,
there are also various diagrams to be addressed.
You have on the left section also precipitation.
You have clouds, where we can call up.
And what's really cool there is actually sunshine duration,
also if we click on it briefly.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Let's do that under the report of options,
of what you can call up and then you have below the precipitation
chart there the sunshine duration, there you can actually so-called
lull windows also very, very well recognise.
Yes,
go to tomorrow then, then you can see there the lull window,
which is then broken down towards the evening.
So for example also something that you can use very, very well.
At SRV a thunderstorm is built up.
The model has switched now.
No longer the Cosmo model, but the ICON model.
From that point of view you have to look there now.
Are the forecasts certainly again a bit more accurate, because so cloud amount, precipitation,
that hasn't quite hit the mark in the past.
That's why you can now look into the future, how the situation develops there.
There's a general section.
Goes a bit more into detail.
The 700 chart for example very good for recognising when fronts come in.
Let's see if there now.
Maybe take a look.
Then we can take a look at something else there.
And then we see each other again, if things continue like this.
Then we see each other again.
look, yes, that's actually already the
tomorrow there, you see,
how the rest of the front
comes in there,
so I find it not
so bad, there it starts
then already, there are already
certain offshoots, there is
then definitely the case,
so it's also not
so bad for preparation,
but let's still
go to the German Weather Service,
there we have
the most varied diagrams, not just
the so-called Foehn diagram
and I find that just neat there,
you have there to choose from
also the Foehn in Austria,
this, sure, we have that
anyway, but also
wind at Lake Garda, has worked
very well, then
something that I in Slovenia
used, that
worked outstandingly,
was Bora diagram, that
also helped me very well,
down there, I find so very
good, and the Mistral for France,
there you can really
under most varied diagrams
choose and
I find that just outstanding
for flight preparation,
there you can really at a
glance also see, when does
what happen, if we now look at us,
we see that here a strong
pressure drop is present,
that means, there somewhere
then the front comes in
and that too is
actually for the weather preparation
yes, very, very important,
but that's also with me on the app
yes, with
integrated. Good,
what perhaps still
as an additional point
precipitation and
cloud amount or
cloud radar, that I look at
actually very, very much at
MeteoSwiss on the app,
on the phone, that
works quite well, also there
there are now and then
forecasts that aren't quite
matching, but precipitation,
forecast I find there
already very good
and belongs for me
then for the next day
always to be included, but I think,
most can do that from the app,
from the phone, so that you should
in any case include
in your forecast.
Good, then I'd
once like to
a wind forecast quickly
go through with you,
once a cloud forecast
with the
various apps
or rather just quickly
with
Burnair, Meteo
Parapente and Windy
and there too there's also
a so-called cloud radar, but that's
more visible on the phone.
Good, then I'd quickly with Windy
start, especially for tomorrow's
day.
We don't have so
far into the future
to look any more, for tomorrow
I'll switch here to
ICON-D2.
We see already, without
me having changed the altitude now,
but from the European
ICON-D2
to DWD,
we have there
above us
so already an entirely different
speed.
44 to 33,
that's still 11 km/h
and
there we then have to
look at the respective altitude.
At the moment, in winter,
I really recommend you
look at the 3000-metre wind well.
It can come down nicely,
break through.
We don't have such
a thermal cushion yet, that the whole thing
can damp it very well or
rather, can push it very well
upwards and that's why
always include the 3000-metre wind for sure.
Perhaps it
even starts only further up.
4000-metre
wind has decreased a bit again
and only afterwards
again into the depths. So there we now have
for tomorrow at
4000 74 km/h world wind
reported at 12.
We'll do now for simplicity's sake
just so around midday
and then it would be important,
that he tomorrow also looks,
what's around midday really
for wind present.
We have certain measuring stations,
also at 3000 metres in our
vicinity, where you can pull up and look,
is that really. Let's go there again
down, 4000, let's go now
down to 3000 again.
3000,
as I said, 45 km/h.
You see that we down there
significantly less
wind have, 25
southwest, so there it would perhaps
even be flyable.
With Foehn, that's also so
leeward, you could perhaps
fly, if there's no precipitation
and if the wind still isn't
too strong. But
with so much,
because it has down there still
ridge precipitation and
not so well flyable. Right.
That means, for us,
if we again a bit
go down, the 2000-metre
wind doesn't fit at the moment
so well. But let's go
down there, then we have
20 km/h,
where you really also our
20 km/h could
approximately
be roughly right tomorrow.
Our station is
at 2150 metres
or so. Exactly I can't
tell you, but there you could then
look tomorrow what's there
at the launch holes.
Usually it's that the south-westerly wind
doesn't really arrive at the Grafen itself
but rather as west-north-westerly wind.
But let's see tomorrow,
whether at 2000 metres
between us can land.
Then we can perhaps,
I still have 10 minutes time,
then we'll go straight to
Meteo-Parapente, see,
what they say.
Then you of course have to
select the area, let's take
our area, Thursday,
the requests down there we don't need to switch,
we're here,
12 o'clock at 2000
metres, they are
though
in agreement, we have there
also
around 20 km/h
wind south-westerly
direction and then
actually there from 1 pm
very strong, then we can quickly
quickly
on the phone
and see, whether at 1 pm
it also starts there.
Then we'll look
at 1 pm
and
there it will be
exactly at 3000 metres
in agreement.
The data not having
very much more yet, but only
3000 metres more than
the wind, which has shown that.
From basic reasoning you see,
okay, strong wind comes up,
here it goes just again significantly
further down with Windy,
uh, with Meteo-Parapente than with Windy.
Then let's see, what
Bernie says.
We have to go to meta-forecast
and then we hide
the precipitation.
Let's look at 1000 metres
for tomorrow.
And there it has also
21, 24 km/h
wind, so
in principle they're
quite in agreement, which means
again, that that
fairly certainly will come
true, or the
more they shift there,
the higher the hit rate,
that that'll also match,
1 pm, so
same theme.
Then a few more
Zimmerlehrer,
unity,
then we see that it also
rather more strongly
lives,
so decent
for sure is for the price.
If we then compare the whole
thing with
first
with the diagram,
then we see that there
also
the diagram still until
yes, sometime late
afternoon, evening, if you
look at it with SAV, then you have
there even a better
time scale, then you see,
that there the whole thing
tomorrow, every
afternoon hits,
there somewhere
then the front comes in,
around 6 pm,
and there it starts, that the whole time
there until then
perhaps also 8 hPa,
here it's just that there
we do have a bit of uncertainty
in the forecast, so
where then also what actually
endlessly gets measured, but
it has a clear
program game, until
in the afternoon it then holds
somewhere, and then
it also does, because somewhere
there comes, then the front in.
I think, if you
thus try, with the
direct comparison,
perhaps also so built up,
all three side by side,
you can
for the respective day very,
very well prepare.
A rough forecast I would
still also a
text forecast include,
so with Switzerland
text forecast read,
I find belongs also still to it,
you have it sometimes with a
not quickly,
yes, visible,
perhaps
Foehn comes up, or
it's low-pressure weather anyway,
low-pressure-determining with precipitation,
fronts are often
forced,
also in the weather report
integrated in the
text forecast, and that's why
it's actually still
important, that that's
included. In Wetter it's
also so, you should look,
you can spend a lot
of time
use up,
or need, that's why
you always have to look, if you
with a rough
view see, yes,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
it's nothing anyway, then I'd
not look too much into detail
with my forecast, but if I see,
hmm, on Sunday it
always looks good, then I'd
look at Sunday really more closely,
and that naturally then on Saturday,
even saying just, now
looking at Sunday,
can come like that,
but can also be that it
definitely
doesn't come, and that's why
it's just a fair amount of speculation,
but of course,
for your own planning is already
important.
They've become significantly better.
That's why you can there now
look a bit into the future.
But it's still also
a question,
whether the data get listed at all.
That's only so much
possible.
But with that,
you can there
with the relevant model
set the models.
I'd just stand that so far
leave standing.
Actually from my side
so far
the overview created.
Just for wind.
Then I'd
the whole thing here
quickly stop.
And afterwards still,
whoever wants, look at clouds
and precipitation.
Though with clouds
I would actually
include.
On the phone.
The animation.
And above all
for the precipitation.
Good.
Any questions
about that yet.
We have to see,
whether we're recording that correctly.
Yes, you, Dani, a question.
Yes.
Respectively, I've seen,
the station on the Grab
is offline
since yesterday.
Yes.
And on the Burner
you can also see nothing.
It has one reason or another.
Yes.
Either it's broken off again
from the strong wind, blocked
or
has another technical background.
But I can't tell you right now.
Okay.
Would you have to inform someone or so?
Yes, it's no use.
No, you have to go and look.
It probably
from the strong wind
broke off again.
That's the latest.
Presumably.
Okay, thanks.
But yes, if anyone's up at Wiefahren,
would be cool if he stops by and we get notified.
Okay, good.
Then we have one minute left.
Then the whole thing comes there, because it needs a moment again to convert and
then opens up another session with clouds and precipitation.
And then I'd say, at the end answer further questions.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you very much.